hey everyone what is going on okay we're
doing something a little bit different
here today with this review now normally
i'll sit in front of my studio or i'll
be in a more professional setting
talking about the lenses the performance
and all that stuff but we're gonna take
this out in the real world with the
all-new 1635 f4 power zoom lens from
sony it's the g lens it's not a g master
it's a g lens so it's in that mid tier
price point i don't know the price
exactly as of yet sony hasn't given that
to us here in singapore but uh if we
have it we'll put it here at the bottom
of the screen if not you'll hear from
other uh sources out there on the line
anyway uh what i'm going to do is i'm
going to take this out with my girl
right here my roddy and she's 3 years
old full of energy we're here at the
beach inside my car right now and we're
going to go outside show you some real
world footage of the camera in action
tracking her also some other footage
we've shot over the past couple weeks
with this so with that
let's have some fun with the all new
1635 f4 power zoom lens from sony
okay so we're here at the beach and yes
if you're wondering why i'm wearing a
mask it is still by law we have to wear
here in singapore unfortunately in
public now if i'm in a private area i
can take it off but there are people
around so
it is what it is
so i mean don't bother leave comments in
the comment section below about it
because we feel the same way a lot of
you do anyway uh i'm now
distracting myself here's praha right
here
actually she loves the water doesn't
want to get in so much but loves the
whole wave aspect of it
smelling away having fun
let's talk a little bit about this lens
hold us again
oh
brian come here come here
come here trying to walk with a excited
rottweiler is very difficult so if
you're seeing some shake in this camera
it's because she's excited and wants to
run around and i'm not letting her do it
because of safety reasons of course
anyway let's talk about the performance
and the feature set of this lens of
course this is a 1635 f4 zoom lens so
that means it's going to come in at a
lesser price point than the 2.8 g master
but also you're going to get some
fantastic performance out of this it's a
much lighter lens in terms of around 350
plus grams and with the f4 you're still
going to get great you know depth of
field etcetera but if you are shooting
in low-light
areas primarily for your work events uh
weddings et cetera et cetera you may
want to offer a 2.8 or rely on your iso
performance of your camera if it can
hold up a lot of the newer sony cameras
the fx3 a7s iii uh a74 that i'm using
right here will work beautifully in that
regards and the iso performance is
really good but if you have an older
sony camera this is something to take
note of and just something to consider
now the powered zoom feature of this is
really cool and it's really good for
creative shots but there are some pros
and cons to it now the pros are you have
a switch on the lens and also if you
have an fx3 or a zve10 you can use that
power zoom switch on the camera itself
to control the lens if you have some of
the newer sony cameras like the a74 that
i'm using you can assign a custom key to
activate the powered zoom and uh
telephoto or a wide angle option on that
lens so you can press the dial let's say
to the right to go wide and press up to
go zoom or to the left to go zoom in so
it's an option but you can't control the
speed of the zoom like you can on the
lens or on the power zoom switch you're
gonna have one of the cameras as i
mentioned so something to take note of
in that regard okay uh in terms of
what's inside we got 13 elements in 12
groups you've got your spherical
elements inside of this your close
focusing distance is 28 centimeters on
the wide and 24 centimeters on the
telephoto aspect of it so you can get
some decent close focus shots on this
and it's great for video as well of
course watch out for distortion because
at 16 millimeters in close focusing
you're gonna get some distortion on that
even right now i'm a little bit
distorted on the focal length of it so
uh it's something to take note of but
not a deal breaker just something to
know about okay uh
i got an excited dog that wants to get
around these rocks right here she's
excited she wants to walk around more
okay
probably not the best idea to be
trying
a review
like this on greatest drizzling too how
about that
drizzling at the beach
with an excited rottweiler and trying to
film a review could i pick a better day
i could have but overall we've been
using this lens for the past week and a
half two weeks and uh through various
different projects and you've seen some
of the projects here on the channel
which we couldn't disclose of course for
you know nda reasons but i have to say
that the performance of this lens is
absolutely awesome so if you're a gimbal
user and you're looking for a really
good internal zoom lens that's
lightweight it's not going to mess with
your weight when you balance it this is
a very good lens to consider
we tried on the rs2 as well and it
worked beautifully now if you also have
that bluetooth grip from sony where you
have the controls for your telephoto and
wide zoom on that you can also use it
with this as well so there are some
options out there with the sony system
to maximize this powered zoom aspect of
it it is one of the talking points of
the lens but i would say the overall
performance to me is the star of it and
for the price point which i don't know
currently at this time in singapore but
we'll put the price right here or we'll
let you know as i mentioned before later
on or you can find from another source i
think it's going to be a very attractive
option for a lot of people out there
especially videographers because this is
primarily a videographer's lens anyway
what i'm going to do right now we're
going to show you some sample footage of
what we've taken over the past couple
weeks to show you some photos as well
and i'll come back with my final
thoughts
[Music]
[Applause]
so as you guys saw from the sample
footage and photos the performance of
this lens is really good i have to say i
mean for what sony's done with it for
the price point it's very attractive now
compared to other lenses on the market
this is a much lighter lens as we've
already talked about this is the
lightest uh constant f4 zoom wide angle
lens out there on the market so that's
also something to take note of for
videographers out there event
photographers and videographers as well
you're going to really enjoy this and
especially if i mention you're using a
gimbal this is great to use on a gimbal
makes the system lightweight compact
easy to carry around and the focusing is
spot on as we come to expect from most
sony products these days right right
okay so really no qualms about it i mean
i can only say
i mean i wish there was an f 2.8 version
of this lens compact in the same size i
think that would be awesome and maybe
they will do that in the near future
because the 1635 f 2.8 has been around
for a few years and i'm seeing how
sony's updating their lenses making them
smaller lighter compact and just stellar
performing lenses i think that may come
nobody's told me anything these are just
my thoughts and my thoughts only with
that so anyway those are my thoughts on
the 1635 f4 powered zoom g lens from
sony let me know your thoughts in the
comments section below is the lens
you're looking to pick up on the fence
about love to hear from you guys with
that take care stay safe like this video
helps us out a lot subscribe to the
channel with that i'll chat to you very
soon take care
[Music]